[Musique]
ça c'était 5 12h30 français gabriela
papadakis et guillaume cizeron ont
remporté le grand prix de patinage
artistique en devançant pour la première
fois leurs éternels rivaux et partenaire
d'entraînement
les canadiens tessa virtue et scott moir
yeux et le duel s'annonce épique dans
deux mois à pyongyang entre ces deux
couples qui s'entraînent sous un même
toit à montréal dans sa quête d'or
olympiques le duo français s'est doté
d'une arme secrète québécoise
une professeure de théâtre que nous
présente robert frosi
[Musique]
chaque état émotif et un état musculaire
la montréalaise catherine pinard était
entraîneur artistique au cirque du
soleil
elle a donc travaillé avec des artistes
du monde entier intéressés par ces
techniques particulières le monde du
patinage va faire appel à ses services
car son approche est unique dans le
monde
[Musique]
je travaille d'abord avec les êtres qui
sont devant moi
leur demande ce qu'ils veulent je
travaille la connexion à soi à l'autre à
la musique au programme à la
chorégraphie au public
on fait beaucoup d'exercices d'écriture
on fait beaucoup d'improvisation on
essaie de pas plaquer un sens sur les
choses mais de faire émerger le sens des
choses un peu comme le travail d'acteur
parce que j'ai une formation d'actrice
donc je vais chercher des choses là
aussi senna qu'elle finit la phrase il y
a quatre ans le couple français gabriela
papadakis et guillaume cizeron était 13e
au monde
ils vont décidé de s'exiler au québec
pour rejoindre l'école les champions
canadiens marie france dubreuil et
patrice lauzon
c'est là qu'ils vont faire la
connaissance d'une singulière
professeurs
ça nous fait évoluer comme comme
interprète comme artiste comme patineur
donc ça nous fait c'est vraiment un
travail qui est important dans le sport
est aussi personnellement parce que ça
développe sa développe une espèce de un
autre rapport on travaille beaucoup sur
sur la relation qu'on a aussi sur la
glace entre nous et
donc c'est un travail qui est important
personnellement s'il est pour nous
les marques et gabriel une seule année
aura suffit aux couples français pour
devenir champion du monde
une consécration qu'ils doivent en
partie à leur professeur complètement en
fait j'ai pas du tout l'impression qu'on
patine de la même façon maintenant que
par rapport à avant ça a vraiment
apporté une dimension personnelle puis
beaucoup plus artistique à ce qu'on
faisait
[Musique]
on a fait grève cela c'est un peu comme
un musicien les musiciens classiques et
il essaie de s'approcher de l'oeuvre et
ils ont jamais le sentiment d'y arriver
et il aime ça et donc de compétition
compétition la maintenance et qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire ou on peut aller pour
moi j'ai encore des grandes profondeurs
aller chercher et on se lasse pas c'est
comme une quête une quête du beau une
quête du vrai de sacrées de chaque
programme
[Musique]
ou c'est la pensée qui soutient tout le
travail qu'on fait avec catherine c'est
sûr que ça fait partie de nos forces
mais ce fait notre arme secrète secrète
non je pense pas je pense que tout le
monde voit bien que que voilà on a ce
quelque chose en plus que catherine nous
apporte par rapport aux autres couples
qui font pas ce travail justement et on
est vraiment on est vraiment fier de ça
parce que nous on aime faire ça et nous
c'est comme ça qu'on veut patiner et
et oui en décidant d'en faire notre
fausse être sculpté par le temps c'est
ce à quoi s'est vraiment ce qui me ça me
voilà c'est ça c'est ce qui me touche le
plus de partager la beauté de partager
l'appui puis une vérité aussi c'est très
simple quand on se connecte quand
l'athlète réussi à se connecter à
l'intérieur peu moment donné dit il me
dit ah c'est ça c'est tout si simple que
ça mais pour arriver là il faut enlever
tellement de choses dont on n'a pas
besoin
[Musique]
aux prochains jeux olympiques depuis en
changeant février prochain un duel sera
à prévoir sur la glace coréenne entre le
couple canadien virtuellement lieu
actuel champion du monde et le français
6 rond papadakis en quête de revanche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une chose est déjà certaine c'est qu'il
y aura un peu de savoir faire québécois
qui va rejaillir sur le podium
vers 3 ira du canada montréal
[Applaudissements]